wonderful president talk to me  beforehand or at the end at the end I  hollered I loved him he stopped and he  said I love you too and then he thought  he said this guy says he's loves me and  I swear I'm a woman  oh it's it it all of these events are  completely Beyond parody I mean it's  it's unbelievable it's unbelievable and  it's funny because these folks love to  say  Democrats and the left you don't know  what a woman is you can't identify a  woman it's so obvious what's a woman  what's a man who's a woman who's a man  and then now it's all a big joke that  Trump thought this woman was a man I  guess some Republicans struggle with  that as well it seems and it sort of  puts into particular perspective these  absurd transphobic anecdotes that Donald  Trump now regularly tells at his rallies